go ha and whatever you're curious about
dive into it understand it and then
rip it apart when i was 10 years old i
took my first hip-hop class
i naturally went against the grain and
that ended up being
my magic
for the first time ever i'll be sharing
my secrets and techniques to my creative
process
so girls performance you will learn the
ins and outs of how to discover your
true voice as a creative
there's so many different ways you can
use movement to kind of unfold the next
group
i'm going to use the curtain effect the
girls have gone from covering the boys
into two straight lines on the sides
within eight counts just feels energetic
it feels surprising and it really makes
a smooth and seamless transition for the
next group
let's break down the power of eye
contact to camera
i've told her that the camera is a piece
of meat and she hasn't eaten in days
in her eyes she's telling the story
and as a viewer we are now mesmerized by
her performance
going drop and chop smooth i haven't
always been confident
the truth is it's been such a long
journey growing up i always felt like an
outcast you know i didn't look like a
commercial dancer so
i kind of took that and turned it into
my superpower
it's about looking at yourself and and
thinking what makes me unique
and once you kind of discover that
appreciate it
and put it out into the world then
you're really using your voice
i really believe that's what it's about
is understanding what's within
understanding what you stand for
understanding how you want to change the
world because that's what dance does
good it changes the world
you can change the world i'm paris gobel
and this is my master class
you